I love the novelist Lawrence Durrell
here's why in the preparatory note to
Darrell's novel Balthazar he writes
modern literature offers us no unities
so I have turned to science and I'm
trying to complete a four Decker novel
whose form is based on the relativity
proposition three sides of space and one
of time constitute a soup mix of a
continuum the four novels follow this
paddles masterpiece the Alexandria
quartet is modeled after this concept
the first three novels tell of the same
series of events from different
perspectives with each new novel
recontextualizing what actually happened
these represent the three dimensions of
space and show that one perspective can
never illustrate the whole picture the
fourth and final novel revisits these
same characters five years later adding
the additional perspective of time
creating a continuum now many people
including Darrell's friends have noted
that saying the Alexandria quartet is a
model of the space-time continuum is
nothing but a semantic device these
people are of course right a continuum
of the sort can only be expressed in
mathematics and not in words but just as
for example the Mercator projection is
meant to give the impression of a sphere
darrell's quartet is only meant to give
the impression of a continue as special
relativity forced us to see reality in a
new way the form of the quartet does the
same thing with the concept of
personality as space and time are
relative to each other personalities are
relative to other personalities as
Darrell's character Balthazar says each
psyche is really an anthill of opposing
predispositions personality as something
with fixed attributes is an illusion I
would go even further and say that
personality as exclusive to one person
is an illusion as well darrell's
continuum like representation of a group
of lovers and friends depicts what the
night Vale podcast Twitter handle puts
so succinctly a few days ago unnamed is
a lie that keeps you from thinking that
you might be more than one single B it
seems to me that the separation of
objects in space leads us to believe
that we ourselves are separate from the
ones we love when in truth we blend into
and work one another in the same way
that time and space do in the presence
of supermassive objects I am an active
part of the personalities of my friends
just as my friends are active
constituents of my personnel Durrell is
so important to me because in the
Alexandria quartet and later in the
Avignon quintet the basic unit of
humanity is never an individual but a
group of friends and to depict the
complexity of that unit Durrell has to
contextualize and recontextualize until
multiple people begin to feel like one
organism he finds the model in
four-dimensional space-time and it comes
off brilliantly it's the kind of work
that breaks down our self conceptions
and shows us what we is
if there's a used bookstore around you
go find something by jor-el the
Alexandria quartet is obviously my
favorite and I think it's the best here
is Balthazar and I have some other
Justine Balthazar mount Mount Olive and
clay and also I'm reading right now the
first of Avignon quintet which is called
Monsur